good to see you sir it's got the
interlocking in wine on your hat right
there as always baseball season is
arrived as it has those already I've
already watched two games are you really
yes I mean that's a sickness you sit
down and you watch Grapefruit League
baseball I'm watching players that I
will never see again
other than this at-bat do you like the
pitch clock I like it you know I tell
you why it doesn't matter to me okay
because I will oh I will tape every game
and I can speed through later as much as
I love to listen to Michael Kay and and
the guys yeah I can speed through a
baseball game in 22 minutes and see
every pitch so I have my own speed clock
no but you know you know though I've
done this sort of stuff before for
various events whenever AMA whenever I'm
recording something and I'm putting
myself on sports blackout so I don't
know the the final score and obviously
if you have a final score of a
grapefruit league game you don't have to
worry about it but sometimes you go too
fast you go too far and now you see that
you see the shot of the other stands and
you know oh no somebody just hit a home
run yeah yeah that's painful okay but so
you don't mind the pitch clock at all
right now um it's just strange to me I'm
interested it's strange because it's not
a there's no time in baseball that's the
whole point a game can last for eternity
it has the potential to never end
because there's no clock
so to impose a clock on the micro part
of the game doesn't make the culture to
me you're you know but then again we
might be of a different era Richard
well we hundreds who are of a different
era well I don't want to confirm that
but but to me the beauty of baseball is
it's not played in a rectangle like
football basketball or in a way hockey
soccer
it's wacked out and every different
space is different from any other unique
that's why there are ground rules in
each facility the defense has the ball
there is no clock
this is what should be relished by the
people who run it and say if you don't
like it guess what
you can't say well pounce and you suck
but it is well it is something that
should be relished in a way speaking of
being from a different year I used to
rate baseball experiences I would cut
out of school on a Wednesday member the
Wednesday matinee doubleheaders sure so
up you take a train up to the Bronx and
one o'clock start and two consecutive
games and I measured that because the
Yankees were horrible in the late
sixties right I had a chance to see
Mickey Mantle strike out and you know
fright but they were horrible I measured
that experience by how long it lasted
and how many hot dogs I ate so if it was
a seven hour day that was a good day
that's a good day yeah to me it's the
paint it's this style of play not pace
of play I I hate the shift I want the
shift out everybody tries to hit over it
and that they're just swinging from
their heels they're swinging like Jesse
Barfield on a bad day every single time
that their uppity boy he would always
corkscrew himself run to the ground
and everybody so last year there were
more foul balls than fair balls hit and
that's a fact that's amazing yes and so
to my constant hits and I am I am
pointing at the shift and saying that's
what it is exit velocity warning he
hated over this shift instead of trying
to hit the ball where it's yes and yet
this is what I don't get I'm because the
players obviously see the advantage in
terms of contractual negotiations if
they have 40 home runs and so on right
but every world champion is still the
team that hits more doubles that's can
steal a base that can sacrifice and
score one run will need one run the Red
Sox the Red Sox in Houston before that
right and you know give me a dust why we
talked about Machado give me Andujar any
day as a hitter in a tough situation
because he can take the outside slider
and poke it down the right-field line
for a double that's what I want to see
in a close game I don't want to see the
guy who's swinging for the fences when
we need four runs you know I want to see
one two runs out of time catch up and
put pressure on that defense
Schiff here on the Rich Eisen show we
were talking about Machado where he
should go you were hoping he was going
to the Yankees correct 100% he's a Red
Sox fan because you see this the a-rod
yeah yeah I thought that would be the
case too and you know it's not because
you'd rather see Andujar which is
interesting by the way Machado is
playing third base I know in yeah so to
me it's just you look around at the
generational talent that the Yankees
have and Sanchez and Judge and obviously
Glaber Torres is gonna be one of a man
to harm might be one of them as well
gotta pay these guys these guys are
gonna have to be paid and I understand
that there's no salary cap but at some
point teams always squawk about the
luxury tax and I know it's not my
Steinbrenner money but once you got the
core team that the Yankees got in the
90s and they had that team that that
center of that team the Jeter and Posada
and pettite and Bernie and all those
guys they only added the veterans that
they might need for a stretch run they
never made the big move together they
got a Tim Raines or they got somebody
like that you know Boggs yeah Bob yes I
mean I can't to this day what the hell
is he doing in a Yankee uniform riding a
horse
yeah winning a championship ah I iced it
off for me
come on Johnny Damon too he had a
problem with Clemens he got he got the
Red Sox stink off of them they weren't
two songs in Toronto right that dumped
him so now thought the broken bat was a
ball yeah throwing at Mike bi was at
that game so was i you were that was
covering it for ESPN
I was just sitting there watching it I
was wild
yeah I was crazy that was a wild wild
night that Subway Series yeah so yeah I
mean it is it's it's just an interesting
it's an interesting time for baseball
and into fans of it I feel kind of bad
that we're sitting here bitching about
shift and pace of play but you know we
still just don't even know where
Harper's going yet obviously that's a
big deal going back to the ship do you
think it's be hope be hoofed be joven
how do you say that on the players too
- to learn what George Brett did his
entire career and wade boggs did his
entire career and Tony Jeter did his
entire career was just to hit the other
way every now and then well to me though
we've had Scott Boras on the program and
he says it is biased against left-handed
hitters the shift always been when you
were kid well the shifty well well
unleash it there lefty came up well
because you're not able for a righty to
put four guys on one side of the diamond
can't get the first base correct right
so lefties and it's interesting that he
was positing this as Bryce Harper was
about to hit the open market that that
is it's biased against them I don't want
to see all these left-handed power
hitters bunt I just don't want to see it
that's not why I go to the baseball what
I go to a baseball game is I love
watching how beautiful it is where you
do get singles doubles you do get
runners moved over you do see that
instead of like well I'm gonna play the
percentages and I know if I put these
seven guys in these positions against
the left-handed hitter about thirty you
know now it'll be about sixteen percent
of the time that this guy actually even
reaches first base well I I just don't
want it I just don't I don't know Mickey
Mantle used to bunt I like though
there's some great plays in baseball
that we don't see enough of right first
of all the fences have been all moved in
since it was 461 so I feel ya 457
left-center and used to see triples the
triples to me isn't one of the most
exciting play but also scoring from
first on a double and the relay from
left to short to home that to me is the
most exciting play and and the bunt the
suicide squeeze those are our that's
baseball to me I agree with you and just
off the top my head the triple Girardi
hit a triple in the 96 World Series that
plated the winning or the war they last
big run say they really knocked Greg
Maddux around in that game six also
scoring on a double from from first base
that's how Griffey came all the way
around a score to end Don Mattingly's
career and then of course the famed
relay in Oakland California yeah well
what Derek Jeter
yes it slapped one on one of the Giambi
brothers
Jeremy they still feel safe I think he's
out still say safe feel safe based on
wishful thinking my eyes watch the
replay but here's the other leg before
there was a rule in the NBA where and
people were complaining about Steph
Curry Oh Steph Curry shoot the layup
shoot the layup shoot the layup be
better whatever no one wants to see
Steph Curry shoot layups no I see Bryce
Harper bunt down the third baseline when
Steph Curry penetrates and and I mean
still a little guy going up against
three big guys and making the shot is
still spectacular for one for one time
no no I want to see Steph Curry shoot
threes I want to see Michael Jordan dunk
like Steph Steph carries the wrong
example because his penetration creates
threes and opportunities for everyone
else on his team and he makes a lot of
those shots when he does penetrate and
it's what sets up his to be point shot
well this also sets me up for another
question for Richard shift before we get
to your TV work here and your your other
work how confident are you that the
porzingis trade opening up to max
contracts for the Knicks this summer is
a caper that the Knicks are set to pull
off and and and get Zion and the draft
even though they've won two in a row now
great job tacking and that they they
don't even know how to loose they get
they get Zion and then a little bit of
the Dolan magic brings to max contract
players together and now suddenly you're
Nick Phantom you you're back in the
playoffs how confident are you that
they're gonna pull this off on a scale
of 0 to 100 yeah I'm hoping that my
confidence can can break the positive
plain so you're negative integers you're
going backwards I the Knicks have been
great at getting rid of people and
getting nothing in return right with
Tyson Chandler and that whole era of
dumping players that Phil Jackson didn't
like and I don't know what happened
behind closed doors with porzingis but
the prospect of a 7-3 shot blocker who
has it
we point shot and who can handle the
ball was was the prospect of a savior in
New York and and just watching the kids
develop knowing he was gonna come back
that was what was keeping me watching
all year now that he's gone I like
Dennis Dennis Smith jr. I like you know
be great to get Kevin Durant for the
last three years of his prime you know
but I like seeing teams develop I like
watching teams come together we're in
the error of the super team know and and
that you know I mean Mitchell Robinson
has been a revelation obviously noxus
looked a kid that looks really good
Max's next looks like a number nine who
might fade III I hope he comes through
there were stretches he looks great
there stretches he looks kind of out of
control he's got the athleticism but I
hope he comes through well our plan just
so you know here on the Rich Eisen show
that we have hatched is to get James
Dolan out of town when free agency opens
up the window opens up July 1st that he
is the is a liability being in that room
when they've got Durant and Kyrie Irving
everybody coming in getting are you
conjuring a kidnapping no no no we're
doing this well I'm not gonna say fully
data sack it's not only legal Mike Dell
2fo a fine man from New Jersey
he is our audio executive he loves music
we're gonna create our own Mike Dell -
faux fire fest okay okay we're gonna
have it on an island of Alcides Escobar
z-- okay it's okay right exactly ready
for the what team is all CDs Escobar on
now he's not a royal anymore right he's
moved on he's on the Orioles now so
anyway we're gonna invite his James
Don's schmucky band JD in the straight
shot to be the lead
where he can be the headliner of the mic
del to fo what are you calling it the
smoke so stressed what do you think
anything that can help I'm okay with
that
just get him out hey well if you don't
get Cheyenne who's your number two
number two well the other kid right from
RJ RJ Barrett right
take any Dookie and the other one radish
what we need to do we just can we freeze
all the other ping-pong balls just like
apparently David Stern froze definitely
moving envelope yeah I was thinking
about that so all the other ping-pong
balls stay down and mess up just make
the next ball a golf ball so you can
feel it you can feel the texture and the
weight and I'm okay with the fix don't
worry about it it's happening you guys
are getting them the good dog sorry no
it's okay let's get to make sure we hit
your team the Lakers in those years in
the 80s when they kept winning and then
getting the number one pick
and then umber to pick how did that
happen Chris how did that happen that
Red Auerbach kept on getting it he got
to hang on at Larry Bird's rights from
well for over a year yeah he drafted
where he Byrd the year before bird
decided to come back to college and then
the Lakers had had Jabbar and then they
get magic yeah then they got James
Worthy
and then they got James Worthy who I
play golf with is a gray so you got
porzingis and then you got Frank Neil
Akina before Phil got out the door yeah
but we traded porzingis and got to pick
that we should have picked this
unbelievable that's being a nut family
in general Mike tell to folks smoke fest
is the only hope amen sort of sort of
like I'm hoping remember that from from
Star Wars you're the last time you play
dr. Aaron Glassman in the good doctor
season two Mondays at 10:00 p.m. Eastern
Time and then on ballers as well you're
blowing up sir things are going well for
you yeah I know I asked you in the
television on the segment if you're
having a good time on the good doctor
what what do you like most about the
good doctor that you're proud about the
most of this program
I like the collaboration that I have
with David Shore is the creator and we
get to get in there and and grapple with
what's the best way to tell the story
and when where the story should go so I
love that collaboration
I love Freddie Highmore the you know I
call him the kid the Brit who was plays
Sean Murphy who has autism and who my
character has mentored and he's a great
partner to work with and what I love
most
now is that I have a new love interest
on the show who's very beautiful and
very sexy which never happens in my
career just so happens to be played by
my wife Sheila Kelly
so that's how we kissed I've kissed I've
had three kiss scenes in my entire
career two of them have been lucky
enough to be with women so I asked her
the third one was yeah my wife is the oh
no the yeah the third in chronology is
my wife hmm
DW Moffat okay the actor DW mom what
wait and what uh what film was this was
it good question it was directed by
Claire Peplow and and Bridget Fonda was
in it and what's the Australians name oh
my god there's many of that Spartacus
and Oh Russell Crowe Russell Crowe was
in it went before it anyone knew all
right much about him and then ballers
that that is just a great black good old
time
Dwayne is a DJ as we call is a great guy
I don't I just honey what'd he call yo
yo yo no I just I just I think I call
him Dwayne but he's uh he's a really
really genuinely great guy and fun comes
to play very busy guy and Rob Corddry
who I get to work with and my buddy
Steve Webber plays my brother now that's
right and we've never gotten to work
together we were really good friends and
that's a blast so and then last one for
you everybody seems to be remaking stuff
rebooting stuff is there any possibility
of getting the West Wing back together
just seeing what you guys are all well I
always that I was misquoted and and the
story got out deadline reported that
Richard Schiff says the talks are on
there wasn't exactly what happened
I was asked about you know would I like
to see one and the answer was yes and
and I have a great idea and then after
talking about it for ten minutes in this
interview I then said it most likely
will never happen from them they left
that part out it most likely will never
happen but I don't want to hear that
yeah whatever happen cuz everybody's too
busy well first of all I think yeah I
think Aaron's really busy he's about to
win a Tony and he's Bob he wants another
Oscar
okay we're all busy and booked doesn't
mean that can't be a new version of it
so what's your idea it's to get out of
the white not be in the white house and
to get to the grassroots and to focus on
where democracy really happens and start
there again you know go back to that to
that which is what I think we should do
in real life if I go back to the very
basic roots of where democracy begins
and make sure on the local level we
elect the right people so that the
gerrymandering and the voter suppression
and all that other stuff doesn't happen
and and my particular specific idea I
won't get into but it is great okay and
maybe it'll come in some other form well
your you've got this idea and so you'd
be in I believe Rob Lowe has just booked
for our first week of April one by one
let me Robin my idea he's not in your
idea okay so let's just not bring that
up when Rob comes in on the second bring
it up he could handle it he's a good guy
okay
all right listen tell him I said hi
I was gonna do I was gonna do like one
by one I could get it all together just
in the same way that I'm gonna take one
for the team to get Dolan out of town a
job well let's see what happens I'd go
I'd go beyond Rob and if he's in we'll
talk about it good to see you Richard
Schiff good doctor on ABC Mondays at
10:00 p.m. Eastern Time let's chat has
the baseball season matriculates I'd
love to the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience